[Music]
shane gray
is that you i don't want to waste my
summer at some camp
i'm shane gray for crying out loud joe
jonas is giving us camp rock vibes after
hitting the streets with a very flat
iron dew
[Music]
this is so crazy this doesn't feel real
the singer took us
way back to 2008 by flipping his cloth
to a joe bro classic
sos
[Music]
in his instagram clip joe also rocked a
major accessory of the early 2000s
scarves like a lot of them
joe's brother also sported a look yep
under that curly wig is kevin he
captioned it ask god a question
for you which makes us wonder what the
heck is going on
kind of laugh at it this isn't the first
time the joe bros entertained us with a
camp rock throwback i don't want to
waste my summer at some camp
i'm shane gray for crying out loud hey
man we used to love this place
three years ago we were campers the joe
bros totally owned tick tock by
recreating this scene from the disney
movie
i don't want to waste my summer at some
camp i'm shane and gray for crying out
loud
and we used to love this place three
years ago we were campers
the jonas brothers co-starred in the
film and even over a decade later
joe nick and kevin are still our
favorite campers
yeah man this is where connect three
connected
and you get to see your uncle brown not
a selling point but they're not the only
ones going down memory lane
it's so [ __ ] awkward
last year demi lovato re-watched their
role as michy in camp rock in its sequel
are you waiting for huh
i just wanted to fit in okay i think
your whole charade
is stupid and immature you're hiding
behind some crazy lie
[ __ ] gt was with demi at the premiere
of camp rock in 2008.
i feel amazing yeah i feel really good
i'm excited i'm
anxious to see the movie and um yeah
and it's cool because i get to say hi to
all the fans that are out there that i
didn't really know camp rock had
i think the jonas brothers have arrived
um but they're saying just like
i love you and all that and i'm i'm
saying i love you too
in 2017 demi and joe joked about doing
an r-rated camp rock 3.
it'd be like american pie meets disney
channel
i love it have you guys for real discuss
this yes we've really discussed this oh
my god please
can we say it right now 2 18. it's going
to happen it's going to happen
our rate of camp rock our rated camps